[Musique]
merci Yanne Chantrel de nous accompagné
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
représentez les Français établieur de
France vous êtes membres du groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain et
vice-président de la commission de la
culture de l'éducation et de la
communication on va parler de
l'actualité et de ce climat en France on
a vu il y a quelques jours des étoiles
de David qui ont été retrouvé taguéés
sur des façades d'immeubles à Paris mais
aussi dans des villes d'île-de-fance
notamment à saint-toin au bervillier
qu'est-ce que vous avez ressenti quand
vous avez vu ces images bah de l'effroid
effectivement ça ça nous rappelle des
heures sombres dans notre pays je pense
qu'on nous on a tous été saisis
d'effroids par par ces images et puis
c'est un fait hein les les actes
antisémites ont redoublé puisqu'il y en
a deux fois plus déjà ne serait-ce que
par rapport à l'année dernière donc ça
c'est intolérable et il doit y avoir une
forme d'union nationale aussi pour pour
protéger et envoyer des messages
d'apaisement et pour être du côté aussi
de des Juifs de France pour leur dire
nous sommes de votre côté nous sommes là
aussi pour vous protéger face à cette
montée des actes antisémites qui sont
intolérables et qui sont inadmissibles
dans notre pays donc nationale
aujourd'hui elle est là cette oui
là-dessus il y a il y a pas avoir de
débat heureusement sur sur ce sujetl on
est vraiment uni on a confiance on est
derrière le gouvernement aussi pour
faire face il y a eu aussi le plan
Vigipirate a été réhaussé protection
aussi des lieux culte donc ça c'est
c'est indispensable et il faut vraiment
que soit condamné très fermement ces
actes dans notre pays tolérance zéro par
rapport à l'antisémitisme et le racisme
dans notre pays ça c'est fondamental
c'est un socle de valeur qui nous unit
et nous devons être de leur côté pourou
et vous l'avez dit on rappelle les
chiffres 57 à depuis le le 7 octobre
géraldmanin dit que 60 % sont dirigé
contre des personnes et et non des biens
et que c'est plus que sur l'année
écoulée comment vous l'expliquez cette
résurgence de l'antisémitisme est-ce que
c'est une importation du conflit ou
est-ce que c'est autre chose oui parce
que la résurgence elle a lieu depuis les
attaques terror teroriste du Hamas en
Israël mais ça c'est quelque chose de
très dangereux je veux dire les Juifs de
France ne sont pour rien dans dans dans
dans ce qui se passe et d'ailleurs les
musulmans de France également donc cette
importation est très néfaste nocive il
faut il faut véritablement la combattre
et puis notre pays a également un rôle à
jouer dans la région hein au niveau
international on a une longue tradition
également diplomatique par rapport à ce
conflit où il faut qu'on soit la voie
médiane aussi de nous devons prenner la
paix une solution à deux états et nous
devons être une force de pacification
quelque part et ne pas Emmanuel Macron
bah ce que ce que ne fait pas
suffisamment Emmanuel Macron quand son
déplacement on peut pas dire que son
déplacement a étéit une réussite quand
il s'est ru là-bas parce qu'il a prené
ce que vous dites la solution à deux
détail il est allé voir parti il a eu
des propos un peu ambigus par rapport à
la colition
internationale contre le Hamas c'est
clair que le Hamas ne rend pas service à
la population palestinienne ça c'est un
fait il y a même eu pendant on l'oublie
mais pendant très longtemps il y a eu
des mobilisations à Gaza contre le Hamas
hein euh justement donc on doit être
ferme effectivement contre le torisme
mais le terorisme ça ne doit pas être
euh lutter contre la population civile
qui pour le coup elle n'y est pas pour
rien et en est d'ailleurs souvent
elle-même victime du Hamas au sein de la
bande de Gaza on va parler d'un autre
sujet puisque lundi vous vous attaquerez
au projet de loi immigration il arrive
en séance au Sénat Gérald haranin dit
qu'il tient à l'article 3 sur la
régularisation des travailleurs dans les
métiers en tension est-ce que vous
pensez que cet article sera maintenu
dans le texte alors que c'est la ligne
rouge des républicains alors ça on verra
le débat nous le dira mais de toute
façon ce texte il faut pas regarder
uniquement l'article 3 il est très
déséquilibré euh c'est un texte
répressif philosophiquement répressif
vis-à-vis des étrangers ça a été même
durci par la droite sénatoriale en
commission donc c'est sûr que il y a la
suppression par exemple de la me qui est
transformée en un autre dispositif mais
ça en revient quasiment à sa suppression
médicale d'État qui
mé d'Ur il y a un durcissement de ce
texte où quand on regarde les chiffres
la France n'est pas le pays qui
accueille le plus d'immigrants donc même
la perception on en parle tellement de
ce sujet et là on va en parler beaucoup
dans ces prochains jours ça fait
tellement la une de l'actualité en
permanence l'alpha et l'oméga de la vie
politique peut-être depuis même plus de
20 ans que même nos concitoyens pensent
qu'il y a plus d'immigrés qu'il y en a
réellement puisque quand on regarde les
sondage même pense qu'il y en a 30 %
alors qu'il y en a 10 % donc il y a des
pays qui en accueillent beaucoup plus
même en Europe que ça soit l'Allemagne
c'est pratiquement le double tous les
pays qui sont autour de nous on
accueille plus le pays d'où je viens le
Canada on accueille trois fois plus par
rapport à sa population est-ce que ce
texte il est pas en face avec ce
qu'attendent les Français parce que dans
les sondages ils disent qu'il est qu'il
soutiennent les Français disent qu'ils
soutiennent ce texte nous on a fait un
sondage doxa pour publique Sénat plus de
70 % des Français veulent un meilleur
contrôle de l'immigration alors meilleur
contrôle qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
comme je vous ai dit il y a il y a pas
une déferlande contrairement à ce qu'on
dit c'est faux et surtout par rapport à
ce texte il y avait une visée qui est
dans son int qui est l'intégration il
n'y a rien sur ce point et effectivement
on considère quand on accueille nous
avons tous intérêt à faciliter le mieux
possible l'intégration des étrangers et
ça c'est vraiment l'angle mort de ce
texte et c'est ça qu'il faut renforcer
et l'intégration effectivement elle
passe en grande partie par le travail
d'où la régularisation et la
facilitation pour les étrangers mais ça
n'est pas que les métiers en tenstion ce
qu'il faut c'est une régularisation des
travailleurs nous c'est ce qu'on va
proposer au niveau de cet article 3 il y
a eu des régularisation par le passé
è c'est que vous allez proposer pas
uniquement dans les moui mais ce qu'on
dit pour tout le monde c'est tous les
travailleurs et ça a toujours été le cas
quand on a fait des régularisations même
en 1980 il y avait des règles ça a pas
été fait n'importe comment il y a une
certaine temps de présence sur le
territoire mais on a tous à y gagner à
ce que des personnes qui sont déjà
présentes sur le territoire depuis un
certain nombre d'années même des fois
puissent être régularisé parce que ça
participe pleinement à leur intégration
justement en France et les métiers en
tenstion c'est problématique parce que
ça peut ch changer d'un département à
l'autre ça peut aussi créer une sorte de
compte vous allez avoir par exemple un
permis de travail un visa pendant un
temps défini en fonction d'un métier
c'est-à-dire que l'employeur a vis-à-vis
de vous c'est disproportionné parce
qu'il va dire ben écoutez si vous faites
pas mon affaire non seulement vous êtes
licencié mais en plus vous partez du
pays donc ça je pense que ça n'a pas
matière à à faciliter les relations au
travail donc nous on veut une
régularisation de l'ensemble des
travailleurs à partir du moment où il
travaill bah c'est qu'on en a besoin en
plus qui plus est donc il faut permettre
cette régularisation c'est nécessaire
pour l'intégration et l'intégration
c'est aussi avoir un volet bien sûr sur
la langue française évidemment mais
c'est aussi d'aller beaucoup plus loin
sur des politiques proactives au niveau
des associations qui pourraient être
financé pour aider à l'intégration sur
le marché du travail mais dans la
société française en règle générale on
c'est vra évidemment l'examen de ce
texte à partir de lundi on va passer on
va parler de ce qui s'est passé au Sénat
cette semaine le Sénat qui mardi a
largement rejeté un texte communiste qui
voulait créer une amnestie pour les fait
commis pendant les mouvements sociaux on
va voir ce qui s'est passé pendant cette
séance avec Marion
[Musique]
Vigreux bonjour Marion bonjour Arian et
Marion on s'intéresse avec vous à cette
proposition de loi qui était examinée
mardi au Sénat par présenté par les
communistes proposition qui visait à
amnistier les faits commis lors des
conflits du travail ou d'activités
revendicatives oui on se souvient que le
pays a été agité ces derniers mois par
plusieurs mouvements de contestation
notamment contre la réforme des
retraites mouvements qui ont donné lieu
à des poursuites judiciire contre des
syndicalistes et des manifestants et
dans certains cas les sénateurs
communistes estiment que ces poursuites
sont une forme de répression syndicale
qui nuis à l'action militante qui
criminise qui criminalise pardon
l'action revendicative et le droit de
résister d'où leur proposition d'avoir
recours à l'amnestie alors que proposait
ce texte des commun et bien le texte
proposait des passer les condamnations
prononcées pour des délits passibles de
moins de 10 ans de prison commis lors de
conflit autour du travail d'activités
syndical revendicativ ou des
manifestations publiques mais aussi
d'ordonner la suppression de ces faits
dans les fichiers policiers tout comme
les données d'identité des interpellés
le texte précise que l'amnistie ne doit
pas concerner les fait de violence ayant
entraîner des interruptions de travail
mais le gouvernement via le garde des
saau qui était dans l'hémicycle a pointé
du Doig les limites de de ce texte oui
et tout comme les membres de la
commission des lois qui avaient rejeté
ce texte lors de son examen au motif que
les critères d'amnistie d'amnestie
prévue était beaucoup trop large et je
vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet le
garde des saau Éric Dupont Moretti vous
partez du principe que dans une
manifestation toutes les infractions qui
pourraient être commises de façon
périphérique doivent être amnistiés vous
n'avez pas réfléchi aux conséquences et
aux effets de bord du texte que vous
portez et je répète qu'un vol commis
dans le cadre des manifestations
amnistié si on est collé à votre texte
je rappelle que d'autres débordement
serait amnistié de la même façon si on
reste collé à votre texte et cela je le
dis très clairement le gouvernement n'en
veut pas mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs alors on l'entend le
gouvernement ne veut pas de ce texte et
le Sénat non plus puisqu'il a été rejeté
massivement 246 voix contre et seulement
34 pour cette proposition a été en
revanche soutenue par par les
écologistes mais pas par les socialistes
Yann chanrel votre groupe a préféré
opter je cite pour une abstention
bienveillante que faut-il comprendre
alors en fait nous on est favorable à
des lois d'amnestie puisqu'on a été
nous-même à l'origine par le passé à des
lois des lois de ce type et
effectivement on est tout à fait
d'accord sur le fait que le gouvernement
plutôt que d'avoir des réponses
politiques aux révolte social qui a eu
ça a été principalement des réponses
policières notamment lors de la réforme
des retraites où il y a eu des débats
assz animé ici même où ça ne peut pas
être une réponse politique la réponse
c'est par rapport à des demandes
sociales doit être sociale par contre ce
texte effectivement tel qu'il est rédigé
notamment permettait d'amnistier
potentiellement des exactions menées par
l'extrême droite ou les black blocks ça
par contre nous n'y sommes pas
favorables que ça soit au niveau du
cadre justement des syndicats en lien
avec le travail mais c'était une portée
beaucoup plus lche qui pouvait amener
finalement à amnistier des choses que
nous combattons donc c'est pour ça qu'on
a eu une abstention bien c'est parce que
c'était juste au niveau juridique on
trouvait que ça n'était pas suffisamment
bien ficelé par rapport à ce qu'on
souhaitait justement amnistier à noter
qu'avec cette proposition de loi les
sénateurs communistes voulaient alerter
sur le recul des libertés qu'il
constateent et sur la tâche difficile
des militants et des syndicats et à ce
propos je vous propose d'écouter la
sénatrice communiste Cathy à poursoli
aujourd'hui nous assistons souvent à de
l'acharnement parfois individuel à des
arrestations arbitraires menant à des
procédures pénal mais au-delà de la
pression judiciaire opposée au
syndicalistes se pose aussi la question
des entraves tout au long de la carrière
blocage de l'évolution perte de
promotion de
revenusan chandrel est-ce que vous
estimez vous aussi qu'aujourd'hui le
militantisme est de plus en plus
contraint oui absolument bah on voit
qu'il y a de des manifestations qui sont
de plus en plus interdites aussi je
pense que c'est c'est inquiétant
effectivement on vit un moment assez
inquiétant dans notre pays au niveau des
reculs des libertés publiques et
individuelles ça ça dat pas de de cette
année mais c'est un renforcement et je
pense que c'est pas à l'honneur de notre
pays justement de de de faire ça de
réprimer de cette manière-là on crée une
tension dans le pays qui est forte et on
n'a pas fini de payer le prix justement
de ce qui s'est passé notamment lors de
la réforme des retraites lors des jilets
jeunes on pense que ça a résolu les
problèmes ça ne les a pas résolu
justement au contraire c'est toujours
présent au bas fond du pays donc d'avoir
une logique de répression uniquement
policière ne fait que renforcer la
violence et et ne fait que renforcer le
camp de la violence qui se durcit
toujours plus éric duponttier a dit que
c'est ce qu'attendaiit néanmoins les les
Français de la de la sévérité un cadre
après les les Français ils veulent de la
justice c'est les deux ils veulent un
cadre mais ils n'étaient pas favorable
non plus à la réforme des retraites et
on ne les a pas écouté on n'a pas écouté
ce qu'il disait on les a méprisé on les
a d'autant plus méprisé on va pas
revenir sur le sujet d'autant plus qu'il
y a même pas eu de vote à l'Assemblée
nationale non seulement on les a méprisé
on a méprisé aussi le Parlement qui les
représente et je pense que respecter les
Français c'est respecter aussi
démocratiquement les Français les
processus démocratiques et à partir du
moment où on atteinte au droits de
manifestation en permanence qu'on
atteint même au Parlement en permanence
à travers des 493 bah on crée de la
tension et on crée de la violence donc
le gouvernement en est également
responsable par rapport aux réponses
politiques qu'il apporte c'est plutôt en
en répondant politiquement aux demandes
de pays qu'on permet d'apaiser et de
calmer justement euh le pays dernier
point Orian le garde des saut estimé que
la pratique de l'amnistie n'est plus
opportune qu'elle qu'elle ne serait
d'ailleurs visiblement selon lui pas
comprise par la population la dernière
amnistie date de 2002 vous vous le
pensez aussi c'est quelque chose d'Old
school non c'est pas old school je pense
que des fois des fois c'est nécessaire
j'aiécole he parce qu'on va
parler mais vous représentez des
Français de l'étrangers alors mais et
mais eff non ça l'est pas forcément mais
c'est vrai que ça arrive en règle
générale après une élection
présidentielle avec un nouveau président
de ça c'est beaucoup fait en tout cas il
beaucoup il il y a en règle générale des
amnesties non ça peut être tout à fait
pertinent quand il y a des dérives
justement il peut y en avoir hein des
dérives policières ou de la part du
gouvernement et donc ça peut être plutôt
légitime effectivement d'avoir ce nous
on n'est pas contre la la philosophie ou
le principe même de pouvoir
amnistier merci Marion à tout à l'heure
vous allez nous parler d'un autre sujet
he dans le club oui de la question des
otages c'est ça je un petit doute c'est
ça évidemment on parlera de la question
des otages et des familles des otages
qui était présente à Paris on verra tout
ça tout à l'heure on va parler langue
française on va voir c'est l'actualité
dans nos régions hier a ouvert à Viller
cotré dans l'aine la Cité internationale
de la langue française inaugurée lundi
par Emmanuel Macron dans les murs où a
été signé l'ordonnance est dicté par
François 1ier faisant du français la
seule langue officielle cette cité dont
il est à l'origine Emmanuel Macron veut
en faire un lieu de partage et de savoir
mathas sarz nous l'a fait
découvrir quelques lignes pour
l'histoire dicté par François 1ier nous
voulons que dorénavant tous les arrêts
ainsi que toute autre procédure soit
prononcée publiée et notifié au parti en
langue maternelle française et pas
autrement c'est ici à Viller cotray
qu'en 1539 fut signé l'ordonnance
imposant l'usage du français alors en
2017 le candidat Emmanuel Macron décide
de réhabiliter les lieux en désuétudes
pour créer une Cité internationale de la
langue française il n'existait pas de
lieu consacré à la langue française
consacré à la littérature consacré à un
auteur consacré il y en a dans d'autres
pays d'ailleurs et pour d'autres langues
ça n'existe que très peu il y a un
exemple à Sao Paolo au Brésil et sinon
c'est absolument absolument tout dans le
monde donc comment on on crée un lieu
qui célèbre cette langue livre poésie
chanson roman sketch slam discours les
hommages et les honneurs d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui ne manquent pas dans ce
parcours de visite qui valorise une
langue vous et au rayonnement il faut
d'abord qu'elle soit efficace et qu'elle
puisse la réalité qu'elle puisse
déchiffrer le réel il faut ensuite
qu'elle soit fonctionnelle c'est-à-dire
que elle permette le le progrès qu'on
puisse vivre dans cette langue qu'on
puisse progresser avoir un métier une
vie
professionnelle il faut aussi qu'elle
soit adossé à des œuvres parce que ce
sont les œuvres de l'esprit qui portent
les langues c'est-à-dire les textes les
grands textes les discours les romans
les les poésie si vous voulez il y a
quelque chose comme une littérarité de
la langue qui contribue à son
rayonnement et puis il faut qu'elle soit
par une volonté politique mais le
français parlé par plus de 320 millions
de personnes dans le monde est-il en
danger on est pas là pour le protéger on
est là pour le faire vivre pour l'animer
si je puis dire et surtout pour montrer
à quel point il est hyper dynamique
parce que c'est souvent en France on a
peur du du français en danger on dit le
français en danger parce qu'en réalité
dès que vous allez dans le monde partout
dans les pays francophone le français
dans une dynamique incroyable il il
s'augmente lui-même en permanence et
c'est ça qu'on a envie de montrer ici
l'augmentation et la plasticité
permanente du français le français est
une langue aussi en expansion parmi les
noms francophones cette influenceuse
anime une communauté d'1300000 followers
à qui elle enseigne les bases de notre
langue on se rend pas compte en tant que
Français ou française qui a il y a une
admiration il y a un respect vraiment de
de cette langue qui est belle qui est
curieuse ce qui est poétique c'est sans
partir dans les clichés mais pourtant
c'est la langue de l'amour le le
français et on essaie au maximum bah de
d'en parler d'une manière ludique et fun
pour quelqu'un qui parle pas français et
de justement de donner cette envie
d'apprendre le français de découvrir la
France une langue à promouvoir et pas à
préserver sauf de l'écriture inclusive
le Sénat vient de voter une loi
interdisant son usage le président de la
République s'y est pour sa part montrer
également
défavorable et on va revenir sur cette
itée mais effectivement lors de son
discours d'inauguration auquel vous vous
avez assisté Yan Chantrel Emmanuel
Macron a parlé de l'écriture inclusive
il a appelé à ne pas céder aux aires du
temps il a dit dans cette langue le
masculin fait le neutre on n pas besoin
d'y ajouter des points au milieu des
mots ou d'étirer ou des choses pour la
rendre lisible il n'a pas raison non
c'est une erreur de sa part et
d'ailleurs il devrait échanger avec des
linguistes qui eux-mêmes disent que le
masculin n'est pas neutre justement et
notutre langue a la possibilité de
d'utilisation du du féminin et ça n'est
pas nutre et on voit même que que quand
on rédige des offres d'emploi mais ça il
y a des études très précises là-dessus
uniquement en masculin il y a beaucoup
de femmes qui ne postulent pas et qui ne
se reconnaissent pas dans les offres qui
leur sont proposées comme si ell ne leur
étit pas destiné donc le ça n'est pas
neutre et quelque part ça a été très
bien dit dans votre reportage c'est une
langue vivante notre langue qui
n'appartient d'ailleurs pas qu'aux
français qui vivent en France ça
appartient à l'ensemble des francophones
qui la font vivre et qui la font vivre
différemment deune manière différente et
c'est ce qui en fait sa richesse
justement et plutôt que d'être abougeris
de vouloir interdire parce que
finalement ceul qui ve qui veulent inter
ceux et celles qui veulent interdire des
choses c'est ceux qui se cell ceux qui
veulent interdire l'écriture inclusive
puisque j'avais regardé ça fait neuf
propositions de loi en la matière depuis
2018 vous n'avez pas de proposition de
loi pour l'imposer donc quelque part
vous ne pourrez jamais osser empêcher
les locuteurs et locutrices en français
de parler de la manière qu'il le
souhaitent cette manière de mettre des
ce qu'on appelle le point médian pour
vous ça abîme pas la langue française
alors après le point médian c'est
quelque chose qui est à l'écrit
d'ailleurs c'est pas à l'oral ça n'abîme
pas il y a même des recommandations qui
sont faites pour par rapport à son
utilisation il y a même des linguistes
qui le dit mais c'est pas à nous
législateurs de dire la manière de
définir la norme de la langue française
parce que ça ça peut mener à des dérives
vous pourriez très bien avoir des
propositions de loi sur le verland sur
l'argot c'est également des des
déclinaisons de notre langue qui qui est
parlé donc je pense que ça que le
législateur simist dans dans la langue
française pour moi c'est quelque chose
qui est dangereuse et qui est d'ailleurs
même condamné par la personne qui a
l'initiative de la loi qui n'a pas de
rapport Jacques Toubon puisque nous
l'avons auditionné également lui-même
dit que ça amènerait une dérive son
texte n'était pas fait par rapport à la
langue française en elle-même au niveau
de sa sa gestion interne je dirais c'est
par rapport aux langues étrangères et
mais Pascal gruni qui est l'auteur du
texte qui a été adopté he par le sén
lundi soir elle était à votre place
mardi matin et elle disait que c'est pas
avec l'écriture inclusive qu'on aura
l'égalité hommees-femme que c'est du
communautarisme et qu'il faut faire
attention car la langue est notre bien
commun qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez
bah je dis que non c'est pas vrai parce
que justement comme je l'ai dit C sont
les mêmes personnes qui ont combattu la
féminisation également des nom de métier
d'ailleurs madame gruni se fait appeler
madame le sénateur donc elle-même
finalement c'est l'écriture inclusive ça
n'est pas faut pas le réduire au point
médian c'est les doubles flexions le
fait de dire française fr mais ça ça a
pas été interdit dans le texte alors ça
c'est ce qu'ils disent sénateur et
sénatrice par exemple ça pas inter mais
leur définition même au niveau juridique
est compliqué peut amener à ça donc eux
disent ça mais nous c'est pas du tout la
la la vision juridique et la portée
potentielle de leur texte des
ponctuations vous en avvez également sur
nos pièces d'identité ou nos formulaires
d'impôt c'est les parenthèses c'est la
même chose que le point Méda c'est des
signes de ponctuation donc en fait c'est
quelque chose qui est présent donc c'est
vraiment des combats
d'arrière-garde de la part de la droite
conservatrice qui utilise ça mais qui a
toujours été qu'est-ce qui est au cœur
de leur lutte en permanence ils ont
toujours lutté contre les lois sur la
parité contre l'égalité hommes-femm ça a
jamais été le camp de ceux qu'il
défendaient et ils font la même chose à
travers notre langue également laissons
les gens écrire de manière inclusive
s'il le souhaite on ne l'impose pas mais
on ne doit pas l'interdire un mot sur
cette Cité internationale de la langue
française hein puisque'on on l'a vu dans
notre reportage euh est-ce que c'est une
bonne idée et de faire ce projet
culturel hors de Paris en plus oui c'est
une bonne idée par contre c'est c'était
important je pense que c'est une belle
œuvre par contre c'est indispensable
comme je le disais de pas en faire juste
un outil franco-fançais de faire vivre
la diversité de notre langue à travers
les différents territoires où elle se
pratique et où elle se parle ça je pense
que c'est fondamental de permettre aussi
la venue d'artiste parce que le problème
c'est qu'on a une forme d'incohérence
sur le sujet vous avez dans un même
temps vouloir faire rayonner la lingues
française mais la politique de la France
même en matière de visa on l'a vu
vis-à-vis de pays francophones est
tellement restri on a parlé de la loi
immigration que on se tire pratiquement
une balle dans le pied c'est-à-dire que
on veut faire rayonner notre langue mais
les francophones on fait tout pour les
empêcher de venir notre pays alors
qu'ils ont étudié français voire dans
nos établissements français hors de
France donc il faudrait aussi que le
gouvernement le président de la
République et une forme de cohérence
faire rayonner notre langue c'est
favoriser les échanges dans l'espace
francophone que ça soit économique au
niveau de l'éducation au niveau de la
recherche et au niveau des jeunes mais
c'est pas le cas à l'heure actuelle donc
il faut aussi une impulsion à ce
niveau-là politique pour faire vivre la
la francophonie et favoriser les
échanges dans cet espace un dernier Mo
Chantel on va parler de votre parti du
Parti socialiste qui a voté un moratoire
qui a donc suspendu pour le moment ses
relations avec l'anupe c'est jusqu'à
quand ce moratoire alors après on s'est
suspendu mais on travaille toujours en
tout cas principalement à l'Assemblée
nationale avec les autres groupes là on
prend des PO vouses plus dans
l'intergroupe mootion de censure vous ne
vous ne vous êtes pas associé à la
France mais la gauche est unie sur le
sujet par exemple ne serait-ce qu'au
Sénat vous avez la semaine prochaine le
texte sur l'immigration et je peux vous
dire comme pour la réforme des retraite
nous serons unis et nous ferons des
propositions communes qui qui sont les
qui sont quasi les mêmes sur ce texte
contre ce texte pour pour modifier ce
texte mais il fallait le faire ce
moratoire oui il fallait le faire dans
le dans le le climat qu'on est alors
après ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que nos
compatriotes restent et sont attachés à
l'union de la gauche à juste titre alors
que ça s'appelle PS ou un autre nom ça
n'a pas beaucoup d'importance par contre
mais la question qui a de l'importance
c'est est-ce qu'un jour le PS pourra
retravailler avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon
votre AVS après je pense qu'il y a des
problèmes avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon au
sein même de sa famille politique hein
vous avez pu le voir au sein de la
France ce qui est important c'est quand
on a des partenaires c'est d'avoir un
cadre démocratique qui permet d'avoir
des échanges pour que tout le monde en
profite pour que ça bénéficie il faut
pas que ça soit une personne qui définit
une ligne et qui décide pour les autres
donc c'est
je pense que l'erreur c'est justement de
ne pas avoir permis d'avoir des échanges
structurés dans un organe structuré à
travers Parlement de l'anubseou peu
importe le nom pour pouvoir avoir des
échanges pour avoir pour décider
finalement de position commune c'est ça
la la la difficulté d'avoir des position
comm donc il faut mettre il faut dire au
revoir à la Nupe et rebtir une autre
union de la gauche pour pas forcément ça
comme je vous ai dit le nom importe peu
ce qu'il faut c'est en tout cas leadre
strure il faut il faut trouver un autre
cadre
quip leader bah il faut pas que ça soit
forcément Jean-Luc manchon mais il faut
surtout que ça dépasse le cadre juste de
l'Assemblée nationale il faut que no
parti puisse être associé étroitement
parce que faut pas être hypocrite nous
défendons 85 8 à 90 % la même chose nous
sommes ensemble au combat contre ce
gouvernement et pour pour proposer une
alternative pour la France et il faut
qu'on aille vers une candidature commune
à l'élection présidentielle je pense que
c'est indispensable si on veut pouvoir g
parce l'heure actuelle c'est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon votre meilleure chance de
victoire alors après vous savez le temps
est long nous somm sommes en 2023 il y
aura des discussions on peut souhaiter
aussi qu'il s'amende qu' change de
pratique aussi pour pouvoir réunir la
gauche parce que on peut pas fracturer
notre camp il avait une responsabilité
il a toujours une responsabilité il est
arrivé à en tête il a réussi à faire
sette union il faut le reconnaître
également mais quand on est à la tête
d'union on a une responsabilité pour
faire vivre cette union et ne pas
fracturer avec ses partenaires je pense
que c'est également une responsabilité
il doit se mettre au-dessus de la mêlée
et assumer la responsabilité qui lui a
qui lui a été donnée lors de l'élection
présidentielle merci entre elle merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin pendant cette première demi-heure